わかりました、毎年恒例の日本質問ビデオを見てみましょう、
シンサン、何ですか、えー、
初めて日本の新しい家に引っ越しするような経験は何ですか、
具体的に注意すべきことはありますか？日本に引っ越しする際の私の
唯一のアドバイスは、一般的に言えば、次のようなもの
です。 一人
で、自分で移動する荷物はそれほど多くありません
が、結婚している場合は、
お金を節約しようとしないで、引っ越し会社を雇いましょう。
希望どおりの引っ越し会社が複数あります。
2つか3つくらい電話して、
それぞれから見積もりを出してもらって、それから
入札合戦みたいにしてどんどん
下げてもらって、実際
に適正な価格だと感じるまで下げていくんです。
日本で引っ越しするときに言いたかったのは、
現時点ではアパートでもマンションでも一軒家でも、さまざまなタイプの住居に住んでいる経験から言えば、
それは通常、実際にそう
する必要はないということです 何でも
いいよ、アパートに引っ越すとき、隣に
住んでいる人たちに挨拶するという意味では、もちろんアパートについてのことは、
人々が正しく行き来するということだ、あなたは
私だ、日本に住んでいたアパートはすべて、
私は一度も住んだことがない 同じアパートに
1年半以上、
長くても2年以上、同じアパートに長期間住んでいる人がたくさんいることは知っていますが、
一般的に言えば、同じアパートに住むことになるのはわかっています。
限られた
期間だけそこにいて、その後あなたは引っ越すことになる、
私が今持っているこの家に引っ越したときにそれを
学びました、
そしてこれもまた理にかなっています、なぜならあなた
は実際に家の所有者であり、いつ家を建てるのか、
そしていつ家を建てるのかということです。
またどこにでも家を建てると、そこに
少なくとも非常に長い間滞在することが前提になり
、その意味では、すぐ隣に住んでいる
人たちに挨拶するだけでは通常十分ではありません。 そうする必要は
ありませんでしたが、
それが慣例であり、
私たちのブロックにいるすべての人にプレゼントを買うためにこれを行ったことがわかりました、そしてこれは私に
2番目のことにつながります、実際に私たちは
その8つのところに行ったと信じています または9つの
異なる家に2回、
建設を始めたときに、「
この家に引っ越します」と言いました、
ええと、またはこの家を建てています、申し訳ありませんが、
しばらくの間うるさくなります、そして
正式に引っ越した後にもう一度言いました 心
に留めておいてほしいのは、
内向的な性格で自分のことだけを守りたいのであれば、家は
本質的に
人との交流がより
多く必要になるため、日本では最良の選択肢ではないかもしれないということです。 アパートのようなものよりも、
日本ではビーガンであることは
問題ありませんが、疑問符が付きます。それから、
デュオリンゴについての質問もあります。私は
そのアプリを使ったことがないので、Duolingoの質問には答えるつもりはありませんが、私はビーガンと同じくらいビーガンでした。
日本に来て約3年、完全菜食主義者です。最近は魚も食べますし、
卵もかなり定期的に食べます。
時々、
YouTube仲間のような人
と一緒にディナーなどに出かけます。
それと
そこにはビーガンのオプションはないので、ご存知
のように、
その特定の環境で肉を食べることに大きな懸念はありませんが、
一つだけ言えることは、これは
もう少し深い話になるでしょう
しかし、
日本でビーガンになるのは米国に比べてかなり難しいです。
その理由の 1 つは、
一般的にビーガン文化が
日本に比べてはるかに新しいものだからです。
米国
日本での生活全般に関する私の一般的な経験則の 1 つは、
米国で人気になったものはすべて
5 ～ 10 年後に日本でも人気になるということです。
この講演で私が本当に話したいのは、
健康についてです。 日本は一般的に、
他の多くの第一世界諸国では実際にはもう許可されていない農薬や食品保存料のような用語を実際に許可しています。その
ため、日本の
多くのイチゴ農園がそれらと
考えられているものを使用していることを私は知っています
日本国外では非常に危険な
殺虫剤だと思われている
それが殺虫剤なのか、それとも肥料という
言葉が
正しくないと思うのかわかりませんが、それは
虫を寄せ付けないか、
植物を成長させるかのどちらかである化学物質のようなものです ああ、
どちらにしても、それは日本国外では
非常に危険な化学物質であると考えられており、
このため、日本は
これらのイチゴを
米国などの国に輸出することはできません。米国ではこれらの化学物質が
米国にあるため、法的に許可されていないのと同じです。
トランス脂肪酸は完全に違法であり、トランス脂肪酸について知ったのは私にとってかなり衝撃的でした。
米国でも食品では禁止されていると思います。
私が
子供の頃はいつもピーナッツバターを食べていました
が、成分の1つは
部分水素化大豆油でした。
硬化脂肪、
あるいは硬化油は、
米国ではもう許可されていないと思います。
なぜなら、
これは本当に体に悪いという証拠がたくさん出てきたからです。
だから
米国のFDAはそう言ったと思います。
私たちはこれを手に入れることができません、もうなくなってしまいましたが、これらは
実際にはまだ日本で許可されており、
これは特に
コンビニエンスストアの食品に当てはまります。なので、私
自身も含めて知っているので、
私が便利さを愛していることを知っているので、このニュースを皆さんに伝えるのは非常に悲しいです 食べ物をたくさん蓄える
けど、
ここ2、3年は
コンビニのジャンクフードにはほとんど触ってないよ、
それが自分にとってどれだけ体に悪いか分かっているから、いつも
コンビニに行くようにしてるよ
日本では非常に便利で、
これらの
食品保存料を含まない素晴らしい選択肢がたくさんあるからです。 普通のゆで
卵とそれから多分一袋、
何と言いますか プレーンナッツなので油や油は入っていません
そのようなものですが、もしあなたがそうで
あるなら、あなたが知っているようなものを食べているなら、
これは
ふわふわの卵サンドイッチのようなもの、またはバッグに入っているサンドイッチのようなピーナッツバターのようなもの、
または
金属や金属のような本質的にあなたが知っているあらゆる種類の食べ物です。 コンビニにある
パンやドーナツなど、あらゆる種類の
ものをポンしてみる
健康に良くないものがたくさん詰まっていることはほぼ保証します 私のように日本が本当に悪いとか言いたいわけではありません
利用可能なオプションの中には
危険なものもあると言っていますが、
他のものを選択すれば
健康になれるでしょう、一度正しい
知識を持たなければならないのはあなただけです。だから
知識を広めようとしているだけです さて、
日本の医療はどのようなものですか
マクロレベルにズームアウトするとどれくらい高いでしょうか 日本の医療は非常に
優れており、それが私が言いたいのは、
比較できるなら特に安いです えー、
ほとんどの人にとっては特に以下の場合は比較的安いです
これをアメリカのヘルスケア、
ヘルスケア オバマケア、なんて呼ぶか忘れましたが、米国やその他の国にある
さまざまな民間保険プランのようなものと比較することができます。そして一般的に
言えば、ほとんどの病院は
かなり優れた設備を備えているので、そのようなものです。
日本ではかなり簡単に MRI をかなり安価で受けられます
えと、それは素晴らしい
ことだとわかりますね、多くのことに非常に優れています
が、
他のことに関しては少し難しい場合もあります。
これが私が言いたいのは、 もちろん、
日本が現在直面している問題の 1 つは
人口減少危機です。
私の経験では、
病院を訪れるたびに、
非常に非常に長い時間待たなければなりません。主な理由は、明らかに病院の数が
多すぎるためです。 そこにいる高齢者は、
当然ながら若者よりも多くの健康状態を抱えています。病院には、
たとえ問題がなくても心配だからという理由で入院している高齢者がたくさんいます。多くの
医師はこれをすぐに認識し、
5人か成功した患者を続けて見て、
彼らがみんな
医者のようだと、またこのせいで彼らは少しうんざりしていると思う、私は何かが間違っているような気がする、あなたは
知っている
けど、私には分からない まさに私は
自分が大丈夫であることを確認したいだけなのです、
安心するためのようなものです、
それなら医師にとっては少しイライラしてさらに悪化するかもしれませんし、そのせいであなたは少し
うんざりするかもしれませんが、
それが終わったら
実際に
深刻な健康上の問題を抱えている人の判断に影響を与えるのは
危険なことなので、私のことをあまり気にかけず、ただ単に医者に診てもらうのに
時間、もしかしたら3時間も待った経験は私もかなりあります。
薬のようなものをくれましたが、まったく
効果がなかったので、
結局、後で別の医者、より良い医者に行かなければならなくなりました。なぜなら、またしても私の
問題は良くならなかったので、
これが一部の人々にとって有益な情報であることを願っています
はい、次の
質問です、それでマルコスは税金は大丈夫と言っています、
それが死と並んで唯一確実なことです、
確かに
ここで二つ述べておきたいのですが、一つは非常に
簡単に、一つは
あなたが日本にいる外国人であり、あなたはそうであるということです。
税金を自分で計算しようとしているのなら、
ただ専門家を雇う必要はありません。優秀な
会計士は常に自分で支払うでしょう。
もう一つ
言いたいのは、
これについてはこれまで詳しく話したことがないと思うからです。
それはもちろん人口減少危機のせいで、
経済停滞のせいで、それらは
もちろん相互に結びついていますが、それらはまた、
あまり扱われていない経済問題もたくさんあります、えー、上の
世代、上の
世代は 日本経済に多大なストレスを与えている
が、
日本経済が
今それほど好調ではない理由はそれだけではない 私の知る限り、主な理由の1つは
全体的にイノベーションが欠如していることだ
本当に人気のあるスマートフォン
会社のことを考えてみてください そうですね、何を持っていますか
アメリカの会社があります 韓国の
会社があります そして中国の会社があります ご存知のとおり
Apple があります Samsung があります 私たちは Xiaomi を持っています うーん、それは
うわーうわー うーん、
そしておそらく思い浮かぶ日本企業が 1 社ほどあります。
ソニーとソニーは信じられないほどのスマートフォンを作っています
私は会社としてソニーが大好きです
彼らは素晴らしいと思います 彼らは彼らが
作っているスマートフォンです 彼らは技術的に驚異的です 彼らは独自のものです 彼らは
比較したときに自分の立場を確立します iPhone や
その他のスマートフォンでも構いませんが、
その市場シェアは、
もちろん
Apple や Samsung に比べてかなり低いです。皆さんが使用するすべてのアプリについて考えてみてください。Snapchat
や Facebook、
Instagram などのアプリも同様です。  Twitter ならシリコン
バレーアプリや Tick Tock はご存知でしょうが、
これもまたアメリカと中国のようなものですが、
税金に関して私がここで言いたいのは、日本
経済は今それほど好調ではなく、
ますます若い世代が増えているということです。 毎年、人々は
年金制度に苦しんでおり、
高齢者は若い頃に支払った社会保障を受け取ることができますが、人口動態
と経済状況のせいで、
この制度は
非常にストレスを受けています。
これに対する反論を聞いたところ、
もし
若者に不当な負担をさせていないのであれば、
平均的な若者が徴収する税金はそれほど
高くないのであれば、それは真実ではないというものです。 そしてこれは、
私が知る限り、実際に真実です。
私が日本にいるだけでなく、平均的、あるいは平均以上の金額を稼いでいる若者は、多額の税金を課されています。
消費税はどう思いますか、売上
税、そうですね、売上税は
3パーセントから5パーセント、8
パーセント、10パーセントになりました、おそらく
また上がるでしょうが、それに加えて
所得税も、特に
上位層の場合はそうです。 かなり劇的に増えたので、
YouTube を始めて数年の間に、
毎年収入のうち税金として支払う割合が
上がっています。
うまくやっていれば、たくさんの税金を支払うことになるでしょう。 日本
この点についてはあまり冗長なことは言いたくないのですが、
現在ジェット機で代替勤務を行った後に就職するための
アドバイスはありません。
教職期間を 3 ～ 4 年超えて滞在を延長しようとしているので、何かアドバイスがあれば知りたいです。
今後はローカライゼーションのどこかに着陸したいと思っています。
これは私も
しばらく話そうと思っていたことです。
現在、日本では AI が非常に破壊的であるため、
翻訳は
私が人々に勧めるような市場ではないと考えています。 その
理由は、
たとえあなたが「はい」と言ったとしても、翻訳
翻訳者は
フィクションなどの分野で常に求められているからです。自分の
本や自分の作品を人間に翻訳してもらいたいという理由で、AI の使用を拒否する作家はたくさんいるでしょう。
映画であれ何であれ、それは
おそらく圧倒的
多数のケースに当てはまりますが、
すでに大量の翻訳者や
通訳者が
AIのせいで仕事を失い始めています。
市場は
非常に競争が激しくなるからです
えーと、ここで私が言いたいのは、
おそらく4、5年前くらいだったら、
私は日本で仕事を探すためのさまざまな異なる方法を自信を持って推奨していたということです ご存知のように、私はプログラミングが
かなり安全な賭けだと思います、
これらは私が過去に
もう一度言ったことです、プログラミングはかなり
安全な賭けだと思います、ええと YouTube やええと
twitch のようなものは、実際には、
より多くのことを学ぶ人にとってはかなり良いと思います 創造的で創造的で、
えー、最近は
正直言ってわかりません Apple が Apple Vision Pro を発表したばかりですが、
それが第 4 世代か第 5
世代になる頃には、世界は
完全に違って見えるでしょう、それは
平等になるでしょう スマートフォン革命の前後よりも大きな飛躍です、
そうです、AR と VR は、タブレット、コンピューター、電話など、私たちが見慣れていたこれまでとは
根本的に異なる多くの
体験を提供することになるからです。
おそらくそれが最も安全な方法だと思います。
これが
最も楽しいことだとか、個人
的にやるべきことだと言いたいわけではありませんが、
おそらく最も安全な選択肢は
AR を伴う何かをすることです あるいはVR、
それがそのために特別にプログラミング
されているのか、そのために特別に開発されているの
か、あるいはメディア企業の
ような会社のクリエイティブチームのようにやってみることもできます。
ディズニーが傾こうとしているのは知っています、ああ、
ディズニーは
アップルのような基調講演にも出ていましたし、 彼らは、
私たちがすでにこのような 3D コンテンツに取り組んでいると言っていた
ので、おそらく
現在多くのスタジオが
3D 拡張コンテンツに焦点を当てているでしょ
う。したがって、私の心の中では、これが真実になるかどうかはわかりません そうで
ないかも
しれませんが、
仕事全般に関してキャリアの安定があなたにとって最も重要ではないが、それでも日本で働くための
仕事のアドバイスを探しているのであれば、それが
おそらく最も安全な方法のように思えます。
腐敗した政治家は3つの異なることの専門家が言っています
あなたのお気に入りの日本映画は何ですか 私は
本当に好きです、ああ、
彼の
名前をそう発音するのだと思います 私が彼の大ファンであるとは言うべきではありません、
なぜなら私は見てきたからです
好きな彼の映画より嫌いな彼の映画のほうが多いけど、
同時に私の大好きな
日本映画2本は両方とも彼が監督したもので、
1本はオーディションで
、もう1本は13人の刺客も彼が監督し
たと思う。
殺人者、そう、彼はイチを
殺人者にしました、ええと、メディアで取り上げられる
ものだけでなく、彼のライブラリを広く探索すると、それは
どれほど
クレイジーなので、
13人の暗殺者のような映画を見つけることができます、それはどれですか
典型的なああR指定映画よりもゴアがたくさんあり、
すでにたくさんのことを言っていますが、これは単なる
驚異的な驚異的な映画です、わかりましたランディは
なぜファミチキがああ、コンビニフライドチキンが最高なのかと言っています、
これは私が前に私が言ったことに関連します、ああ、フライドチキン
外国人は
日本のコンビニについて話していますが、
一般的な意見としては、
これは素晴らしい、すべてがとても楽しい、すべてがとても
良い、すべてが
素晴らしい、そしてやはり日本のコンビニは素晴らしいもので、非常に
便利ですが、私はかなり
怖いです。 うーん、
面白い鶏肉にはどんな油が使われているのでしょう、
気をつけてくださいね、それではアンソニー・ラムが
非常に興味深い質問をしてきました、
かなり長いので全部は読めませんが、要するに
彼はこう言っているのです、わかりました、
やり方はわかりました 日本人、
日本を取り巻く文化はここ
数年、
ストリーミングサービスやその他のツール、そして
インターネット全般を通じて変化してきましたが、
日本の文化がどのように変化すると思いますか? 日本は
今、窮地に陥っています。
これについては、このビデオの前半で話しました。
日本経済は
それほど好調ではありませんが、
これには証拠があり、スマートフォン市場と同様に、
多くの食品に含まれる
成分が
それほど素晴らしいものではないこと、そして
もちろん年金が膨れ上がっていることについて話しました。 制度と
人口減少危機による増税
消費税が近い将来
また上がることはおそらくご存知でしょう
日本には何が待っているのでしょうか
これについては2つの見方ができると思います それはガラスがどうかのどちらか
です
もちろん半分水が入っているか、グラスが半分空か、という
より悲観的な議論は、日本経済と人口動態に関して言えば、この変数の方程式は
日本には未来がないということだと思いますが、
このような日本人の人口は、
どの国も災いを招くレシピです。 この状況から抜け出すことができるのは、
ええと、
多くの移民を受け入れることによってのみこの状況から抜け出すことができた人たちです。おそらく
ドイツが成功例だと思います。それはドイツだったか、あるいはフランスだったかも知れません。
正確には思い出せませんが、
もし間違っていたら申し訳ありません。 それは誤解だが、
もちろん日本は
毎年大量の外国人を受け入れないことで悪名が高い、
相対的に言えば日本は依然として
非常に
日本的な国である、より
悲観的な議論があればあるほど、
日本は決して変わらないし、
あなたが親切にできるうちに撤退するだろう そして私たちはこれを実際に
かなりの数の若い成功者で見てきました 単に
成功したばかりの若者ですら
日本を出国するのです 多くの日本人が
少し
成功すると最終的には日本を出ていくのです
税金がかかるからです それほどそうだったのか、あるいは
日本の外の未来は明るいから、
彼らがそう思っているようだ、あるいは彼らが
まだ
日本にいることを信じていなかったのか、と言うのが最良の方法かもしれないし、
証拠はたくさんあると思う それが起こる可能性は非常に高いと思います
が、実際のところ、私は、
日本がこの状況を乗り越えることができると信じています、
ええと、50年かかるかもしれませんし、
おそらく多くの成長
痛があるでしょうが、その理由は私がそうする理由です。」 私が個人的に
楽観的なのは、日本
文化と、この
前の日本における日本全体の歴史のおかげです Q 私が
作ったビデオです 私は日本がどうだったのかについて話しました 私は非
クライメガ衝上地震について話しました
日本がどうだったのか 私は
その統計は全地震のうち 25 位だったと信じています
世界で起こる地震は、
日本かそのすぐ近くで起こります。なぜなら、日本は
プレートの上にあるからです。私は、300年ごとに
日本がこの非
クリメガ地震に見舞われると信じています。10年
前に私たちが見た311の地震を想像してみてください。
ええと、
12年前、とにかく、さらに広範囲の場所でのみ発生すると想像してください。なぜなら、
それは単一のプレートではなく、複数のプレートにまたがって起こるため、
日本は
この大規模な地震に
比較的近いうちに見舞われると予想されます。 近い将来、日本の歴史を見てみると、
それはデータがある
限り300年ごとに起きていることだ
私が言いたいのは、
日本はまだここにあるということだ
私たち皆が愛する日本は、
私が愛している日本はまだここにあるということだ 非常に多くの災害に見舞われました ええと、
何度も何度も、そして
そのたびに間違いなく言えますが、彼らは灰から立ち上がって、より良いものを作ることができました、地震についても言えるかもしれませんが、これはまた別の例かもしれません
ここでは軽く扱うつもりです、これは
デリケートな話題だからですが、第二次
世界大戦後です、第二次世界大戦後、日本は良い
状態ではありませんでした、そしてもちろん、
アメリカ人が入ってきて、彼らは
少しの間占領していました でも、
あっという間に日本は
世界第二位の
超大国になってしまった 日本は実は
灰の中から立ち上がって、向こう側から這い上がるのが得意なようだけど、
状況はもっと悪くなるだろうと私は思う
彼らが良くなる前にもっと悪化するだろう
けど、私にはそれを乗り越える準備ができているし、
特に
私の娘たちのような若い世代の日本人は
非常にタフで
立ち直る力があり、これから
成長していくだろうと楽観視している。 おそらく比較的
困難な時期にあると思う
ので、
日本がこの状況を乗り越えられると思うと、彼らが乗り越えた
とき、若い強くて
立ち直る世代が
日本をさらに良くすることができると思うなら、
私はその方向にチップを注ぎたいと思います」 私は
日本の将来について楽観的です、そしてそれが
ビデオの終わりに明るいメッセージであることを願っています。そう
しないととりとめのない話になりますので、
ビデオを見てくれてありがとう、
すぐにまた皆さんと話します。